مترو انفاق لندن مغلق العاملون في اهم
شبكه مواصلات في العاصمه البريطانيه
مضربون ومعهم مئات الالاف في البلاد من
مدرسين واطباء وموظفين حكوميين
منهم يلجاون الى بنوك الطعام لانهم لا
يستطيعون شرعه
عشرات الالاف من الموظفين تظاهروا وسط
لندن هذه ايما طبيبه مدربه عن العمل مع
زملائها لليوم الثالث على التوالي قالت
لنا قبل صعودها على المنصه انها لم تتخيل
يوما ان تترك المستشفى لتخاطب هذا الحشد
الكبير من الناس لكن الوضع لم يعد يطاق
الحكومه لم تحرك ساكنا ومن المؤسف اننا
للاضراب لكننا نريد ان نبقي الاطباء في
بريطانيا بدلا من المغادره الى استراليا
او كندا او نيوزيلندا حيث الظروف والاجور
افضل
هو اكبر ايام الاحتجاجات منذ بدات موجه
الاضرابات الصيف الماضي
وبينما تشدد النقابات العماليه مواقفها
وتزيد من ايام الاضرابات تمضي الحكومه في
نهج
[تصفيق]
ها الرب بعوده هؤلاء الى اعمالهم وخفض
معدلات التضخم وزير الخزانات البريطانيه
اعلن ميزانيه العام المالي الجديد متعهدا
بتجنيب البلاد ركودا اقتصاديا متوقعا لكن
دون نزول عندما طالب المضربين
ارتفاع معدلات التضخم هو السبب الجذري
للاضرابات التي نشهدها في الاشهر الاخيره
سنواصل العمل بجد لتسويه تلك النزاعات لكن
بطريقه لا تزيد من التضخم ستواصل الحكومه
دعم فواتير الطاقه حتى يونيو المقبل
وستعلق فرض ضرائب على الوقود لكن هذه في
نظر المضربين اجراءات تؤخر غلاء اضافيا
ولا تخفف من الغلاء الحالي محمد المدهون
الجزيره لندن